that's actually a really uh
really interesting reflection about
about romantic love and its role
in colonizing the wallpaper of your mind
if you think
of your mind if you think of your inner
life as a kind of movie right as a kind
of
narrative unfolding right your inner
life
as cinema then to meet someone
that you fall in love with to meet
someone that
takes your breath away is to decide very
quickly you want them in every
scene think about it i mean to fall in
love
is to decide you want the person around
in every scene you know when i watch a
movie
that i love and i fall in love with the
character
i never get bored i want them in every
scene i want them
to fill the screen i want
them to fill my inner life and that's
what happens when you
partake in a relationship when you enter
into a dance
with another person don't you think my
friend when you enter into a dance
when you enter into a dance with another
person you are essentially
saying i want you in every scene i want
you
to be the star to be the main character
in my inner life and the reason i think
this is so significant is because in a
way it's a miracle
that it can last right choose your
partner wisely because
i mean when i think of myself it's such
a gift of generosity
and a miracle that somebody could ever
find me
tolerable for extended periods of time
that they want me
as part of the sort of default
reoccurring character in their movie
what a
commitment and a choice and an
invitation to make
to another person and the thing is again
i have no issue
with such a thought like i'm a romantic
like when i'm in love
i do want the girl in every scene when i
wake up with her i'm grateful when i
fall asleep next to her i'm
grateful when i watch her get dressed in
the morning i'm grateful when she comes
out of the shower
naked i'm grateful when she washes her
hair i'm grateful
when i get close enough to smell her i'm
grateful when she sits at her computer
and does some work i'm grateful
i'm just grateful she's in my movie i
want to live in that cosmology
and i want her to be the character
that's never
not there i have no problem with this
again
this is what love is for me right this
kind of
virtual reality this this cosmology
shaped like a heart inhabited by
these two people but then but then my
fear
right my terror of abandonment comes
from the insecurity or the belief or the
fear that
maybe i'm not lovable enough to be the
star of someone else's movie
like for a girl to pick me to be in her
movie all the time
is something that i just am
terrified i could never fulfill for
anyone like how
could she want me in her movie all the
time won't she get bored of me or
what if one day she wakes up and she's
just annoyed at my presence she's just
annoyed at my habits she's just annoyed
at my rhythms
she's just annoyed at my smell she's
annoyed at my farts she's annoyed
that i'm around she's just tired
of what i
am she doesn't want me in her movie
anymore she doesn't want me in her
screen anymore and then she abandons me
there's so much trauma there because
that's the fear
right even though i don't harbor
um the the the thought that i could ever
stop loving someone i yeah i'm terrified
that
someone will stop loving me
wow i'm gonna work on that that's some
that's some deep
pain i have there and also some
some something i need to kind of probe
and engage with intensely do i feel that
i am deserving of someone else's love
enough for them to want me in their
movie all the time
for them to want me in their movie for
life
because i certainly dream about having
someone in my movie
for life to take the journey with that
person and i just don't know if um
if i'm willing to believe that somebody
would want that you want me
to be that in their movie yeah